[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar deploying sars kobe 2 wastewater
monitoring in kansas a case study and
adoption of high-throughput automated
sample processing i am kayleigh bach of
labrads and i'll be your moderator for
today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by saris nanosciences
to learn more visit sarisnano.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
justin hutchison
assistant professor in environmental
engineering
in the department of civil environmental
and agricultural
engineering at the university of kansas
dr hutchison you may now begin your
presentation
thanks kaylee as kaylee mentioned i'm
justin hutchison assistant professor
here at the university of kansas um
today giving a presentation on deploying
sars cov2 wastewater monitoring in
kansas and so going to be
having three objectives that we'll
highlight here in a few moments through
a case study and then demonstrating the
capabilities uh that an automated
high-throughput sample processing has
given us the ability to do
increased monitoring in kansas
so our case study
is going to be largely focused on
lawrence kansas and so lawrence kansas
is a university community with a stable
population base of about a hundred
thousand
and then plus or minus 30 000 students
depending on the season
so as school lets out those students can
go home frequently and then when we're
in session we can have higher student
populations i introduced this map as
kind of a beginning point so this is
case data that we had for lawrence and
so i'll give you a few moments to think
about this as we move through some of
the introductory slides but uh i'd like
to see if you can guess what some of
these red intense areas are which
correspond to high
19 cases versus the blue areas
if you think you have some information
on or hypothesis of the population
targets
for these red high covet 19 cases versus
the blue low coven 19 case areas
but with that we'll get go ahead and get
started on the introduction and so
as many people have probably seen in the
news wastewater based epidemiology is an
emerging method
this has been used prior to the covet 19
pandemic
the probably largest area of research
has been used
in illicit drug monitoring and so there
have been lots of studies out there that
have
made efforts to detect
illicit drugs in wastewater to
understand uh potentially uh use of
those drugs within a community
uh before
the covet-19 pandemic there were also
early warning disease outbreak
indicators uh so we've been using uh
enteric virus monitoring in wastewater
for a very long time norovirus
measurements hepatitis a
poliovirus a fairly large study in
israel
on a 2018 paper that was looking at a
silent endemic of poliovirus and then
kind of
the hot topic right now is this idea of
using
monkey pox monitoring
using wastewater based epidemiology to
monitor monkey pox as kind of this
emerges as a concern
within communities
and then there have been attempts to do
prevalence data monitoring so to get a
sense of the magnitude of
the concentrations of the virus and the
wastewater and then again a little bit
of effort in kind of taking that
information back so you have high
concentrations of these viruses or maybe
low concentrations can you take that
back to get a sense of how much disease
is in a community
one of the limitations of wastewater
based epidemiology is this idea around
taking prevalence data that magnitude of
concentration and determining a specific
specific number of cases
and for the most part uh we are not
there yet and it will be probably a very
long time before we can take a
concentration that we find in wastewater
to use that to predict the number of
cases in the community largely because
of the uncertainty on both sides so if
you look at an individual that is
shutting sars cov2 over the span of
their illness that shedding rate or the
amount
of virus that individual is shedding can
span six orders of magnitude and so that
six orders of magnitude introduces lots
of uncertainty when you're trying to
take these concentration data and waste
water back to case number
so for the most part uh prevalence data
we're doing very good on that and i'll
highlight that in this presentation but
again i think a limitation or maybe not
a limitation but something that should
be acknowledged is that taking this
prevalence data and connecting it back
to the number of cases is something that
we're not quite there yet as a field
wastewater based epidemiology
epidemiology efforts have grown with
national and international coordination
and so you've seen lots of communities
jump on board to start monitoring
sars kovi to concentrations in
wastewater lots of dashboards out there
and this is just a dashboard covered
poops 19 that's looking at the number of
dashboards that are available
universities countries and sites that
are participating in this monitoring
effort and so you zoom in on kansas and
right here
the university of kansas has been
leading the wastewater based
epidemiology efforts and monitoring
wastewater concentrations throughout the
state of kansas
and so that's something
that we started in march 2020 at the
beginning of the covet 19 pandemic and
we have been continuing to date
one of the strengths of wastewater based
epidemiology is understanding trends of
disease in a community and so when we
look at what wastewater based
epidemiology efforts can do
it allows us to see those trends and
changes in occurrence and so
one of the things that has been
mentioned many many times is this idea
of early detection of occurrence and so
when papers were first starting uh to
come out about uh sars kovi to
monitoring and wastewater there was lots
of effort or lots of research out there
they're saying that we were detecting
this in the wastewater five days uh
before the clinical tests were showing
uh positive cases and we'll highlight in
the
data and one of the objectives here that
this often has to do with the
uncertainty around clinical case testing
and so when you have these high
frequency intense campaigns for clinical
testing
the argument is is that wastewater
monitoring can offer you that same level
of information for the community
assessment of community infection again
that's one of those ideas we can track a
disease
prevalence in a community so we see an
increase in the community we see it
leaving potentially community um but we
really can't tell you the number of
cases that uh this number of cova 19
cases that would be in the community
risk assessment so risk to utility
workers and those exposed to raw sewage
this has been a very hot topic on the
lab side we tend to treat our samples at
a bsl 2 plus almost to a bsl3 level when
we're handling these samples but a lot
of the times
there is some risk to these potential
operators that are collecting those
samples for us and this is something
that is an ongoing area of research and
then viral evolution so source tracking
of the virus this is again very
difficult um there is some work on uh
cryptic lineages so this idea of we're
observing these sars cov2 variants and
wastewater that don't necessarily have
an equivalent in the clinical community
and so it's this idea of where these
variants coming from
but for the most part what we can do
when we look at the the identity of
variants and wastewater is we compare
that to what the clinical community is
studying and what the clinical community
is identified are the variants of
interest and so once the clinical
community has identified those variants
of interest we often can go back into
our wastewater samples and also look to
see if we can identify those variants of
interest
in general kansas is um and this is a
good thing behind the curve and variants
emerging within our community and so on
the clinical side variants of interest
are often well established before we see
them in kansas and so we often have
access
to those variants of concern in those
databases and so we
are often seeing these variants of
interest emerge in our wastewater at the
same time as the clinical testing side
of things
so the big motivation around wastewater
based epidemiology and why these under
efforts were really undertaken
especially in the early parts of the
pandemic is clinical testing limitations
was really driving these pool testing
options
and so when you talk about clinical
testing you need thousands of tests to
be able to evaluate a community whereas
in wastewater testing you only need one
wastewater sample
and so most of the times we're
collecting a 24-hour composite sample uh
from that wastewater community and so we
can do and process that one sample to
get a sense of the community health or
the prevalence of
cova 19 within one community
and so these uh efforts uh again started
very early in the 2020
january 2020 even to the end uh to some
extent at the end of 2019
and then a lot of effort has gone around
to reporting these values in a
centralized database and so the cdc has
set up a national wastewater
surveillance system and so a lot of
utilities especially in the united
states are reporting this into the
central database
similarly ku started pool testing and we
started in march 2020 so this was uh
before
sars cov2 and the corresponding cova 19
disease really impacted our community so
we had a few months of where we had no
detection of sars-cov2 concentrations
and wastewater but that also meant that
we were uh
very much in the field and detecting
this right when this did hit our
communities and so what we did is we
could test and these tests told us if
the catchment or that sewer shed
if the stars cov2 was present increasing
or decreasing in a community
the wastewater based epidemiology
especially in the early stages of the
pandemic gave us a week's notice uh when
clinical testing was limited
it helped our kansas communities prepare
for spikes especially in our rural
communities
where both clinical testing was uh not
very
prevalent and also general
health community resources
may be more limited in rural communities
and so when we were doing this
monitoring we were working closely with
our state regulator
who was then passing the information on
to the regional
county health departments
wastewater based epidemiology showed
concentration of virus in the sample but
again
we weren't
and cannot still tell people the
specific number of cases
and again lots of headlines out there
and so if you do some google searches
you can find um that we've been doing
this again for quite a while and there's
lots of there was lots of news interest
in these developing efforts
i think one of the things
that's important to highlight when uh if
someone's interested in and launching
these is that our communication
strategies and how we communicated our
results from our wastewater based
epidemiology efforts really evolved over
these last two plus years and so when we
were in our pilot phase
which was you know can we do this are we
interested in doing this we were working
closely with the city of lawrence which
is the hometown of the university of
kansas and so the city of lawrence was
really great um
they
were providing us samples we brought
those samples back to our labs
concentrated the virus extracted the rna
and then quantified and then we
reported these informations
with a
close partner at the kansas department
of health and environment
after our kind of pilot phase testing we
started expanding this to more of a
statewide testing phase and so again
this kind of took on a very similar
structure where local municipalities
were sending us the samples which is
highlighted in the blue arrow
we were extracting the virus quantifying
the virus and data processing here at ku
and then we were reporting the data and
in general we kind of took the
philosophy of giving
the data out to as many people as
possible and so we always reported our
data back to the local municipalities
if we had the direct connection to the
local health uh county health
departments we sent that data directly
to them and then again we sent this
information on
to our state regulator the kansas
department of health and environment who
then would also follow up with local
county health departments
and so again
kind of a philosophy based you know we
wanted to get this data out to as many
people and really we wanted to get the
data out to
anybody that was interested in seeing
this
and then for the most part the
dashboards
which have become pretty common and
popular
we mostly relied on local municipalities
showing interest and if they wanted to
report and develop a dashboard and so
lawrence developed a dashboard which is
still live
and the link is there
if you're interested in seeing that
as we kind of enter what i
think of as more of a mature
phase of our wastewater based
epidemiology efforts
this got even more complicated and so
again
we brought on another entity the kansas
health and environmental laboratories
which are the labs that are for the
kansas department of health and
environment and so we started splitting
samples
since we were monitoring many counties
in the state of kansas and so again
municipalities are still sending us
samples we split those based on the labs
the labs are responsible for
quantification and data processing and
then the reporting also got a little
more complicated and so at the
university of kansas we're still
reporting to the local municipalities
and sending this information onto the
kansas department of health environment
part of
my learning process is realizing that
our kansas department health environment
kind of is a little bit of two entities
where you have the health side and you
have the environment side
and so
a little bit more communication had to
occur between our environment and our
health side and so that's uh fairly
underway and fairly established and so
then our health side is reporting
our concentrations to the cdc through
that national wastewater surveillance
system and again also disseminating to
these local county health departments
so again i think an important point to
make for this is that these
communication communication strategies
have really evolved over the process
and again we largely took the philosophy
of trying to get this information out to
as many people as possible
so i mentioned objectives three
objectives that i want to highlight for
this talk is identify potential benefits
of sars cov2 wastewater surveillance as
an early warning indicator of an
outbreak in a community during
infrequent clinical testing periods
provide evidence that suggests sars cov2
wastewater measurements offer similar
community level health information as
high frequency clinical testing
and then last recognize how an automated
workflow can increase capacity and
reduce
total processing time
right so
for the first two objectives we're going
to use a case study
and for that first objective
specifically where we're looking at
wastewater surveillance as an early
warning indicator so again we're in
lawrence kansas
we collected this data
from june to december 2020 and so this
is about a six-month window where we're
presenting data from the case study
in this particular community we have two
sewer sheds so on the bottom left we
have the what we refer to as the
wakarusa sewer shed
and then kind of the right top is the
kansas sewer shed and these sewer sheds
uh mostly uh flow into the respective
wastewater treatment plants and i say
mostly because wakarusa actually the
sewer shed actually flows to both plants
and so realizing those uh
differentiating flow patterns was really
important to account for uh when we were
looking at our sars cov2 concentrations
and making that connection back to the
case data that we were getting
so again counted for that wastewater
flow as the wakarusa sewer shed and
flowed to both
utilities
another concept that i'll highlight is
the wastewater strength and so
wastewater has it can be diluted
especially when you have rain events and
so we wanted to account for that varying
wastewater strength using normalizing
biomarkers
and then last coven 19 cases were
geocoded by location within the two
sewer sheds and this data was obtained
from the douglas county health
department
and i mentioned earlier in the beginning
of this presentation the red versus the
blue and so red is high case data so
this is the covet 19 cases and blue is
lower case counts
and in general we found that the red
intense areas corresponded to
high student density populations
and we confirmed what we were observing
with the geo geocoded case data by going
into the sewer system and so this is a
kind of sub sewer shed
testing popped open a manhole grabbed
some samples
that were specific to these communities
maybe in the higher intense red versus
the blue and uh observed in our
wastewater that this was also true that
our wastewater from these student
communities tended to be quite higher
than communities that might be for
example single family residents home
more in these kind of blue areas that
you see on this map
so when you look at wastewater flow it's
important to realize that there's going
to be some variation and so if you're
doing a grab sample it's important that
you realize if you take a grab sample at
maybe a low flow event where maybe not
too many people are showering or
flushing their toilets versus a high
flow event
where you might have lots of people
showering or lots of people flushing
their toilets so for example in the
early morning when people are waking up
it's also important that you distinguish
whether you're a weekday or weekend
so some of our communities just because
of limitations
do have to do grab samples but in
lawrence we did 24 composi 24-hour
composite
samples and so we collected a sample of
wastewater that was representative of
that 24-hour period
however it's also still important to
note that you can get variations in flow
from day to day and so we saw that
variation in flow within a day mostly
just because of human patterns
but you can also get variation in flow
because of rain events for example and
so
infrastructure systems are not perfect
uh they can be leaky and so when you get
rain events you get infiltration and
infusion so that water coming from
outside into the pipe which can dilute
your waste water
and we also see this in the lawrence
wastewater treatment plants and so here
again
when you look at
the kansas wastewater treatment plant
you know
here we're about one million gallons per
hour and then when we have these large
rain events uh the one can jump by a
factor of 2.5
so 2.5 million gallons per hour and so
again these large flow events
can be indicative of diluting your
wastewater which is something that's
important to account for if you want to
start comparing
for example between days and weeks
i mentioned wakarus is a little bit
different the wakarusa treatment plant
is flow limited and so when we have
these really high excess flow the
wakarusa plant will divert some of its
flow to the kansas
so to account for that variation in the
wastewater strength we took four
measurements biological oxygen demand so
this is a ready readily available
regularly measured
biomarker that we can use to normalize
our sars cov2 concentrations ammonium
also readily available regularly
measured in wastewater treatment plants
the next two
we measured more in the laboratory the
university laboratory creatinine it's
indicative of human activity and the
reason why we selected creatinine
is that it has a similar half-life to
sars cov2 in a wastewater distribution
or collection system
and so this
biomarker could be important to include
so that you understand uh sars cov2
virus decay in that collection system
and so if you have a really big
collection system and the wastewater
sits in there for a very long time that
sarsko v2 virus has more time to decay
in the
system however creatinine is excreted uh
in urine and so that's a bit different
than the stars cov2 virus which is
excreted in feces so we also monitored
mitochondrial dna and again the idea
there for selecting that was excreted in
human feces
now the much more popular common method
for normalization is the peppered mild
modeled virus or pmmov which is an rna
based virus that's also excreted in
human feces and so we also now measure
that but in these earlier stages of the
pandemic we did a fairly large
comparison of four different biomarkers
to account for that variation in
wastewater strength
of methods are out there to concentrate
that sars cov2 virus
in particular for this study we were
using a 12 peg solution followed by
extraction
at the beginning of the pandemic you had
electronegative membranes ultra
filtration and general centrifugation
steps
we tested uh all four of these and in
general our recoveries were best with
the peg precipitation
and so we used a peg a 12 pg solution
with a bovine serum albumin
that improved our recoveries our
recoveries which were measured with a
surrogate virus nearing hepatitis virus
could be upwards of 32
however it's important to note that uh
viruses sarge cov2 and mhv
like to partition between different
phases and so when you have a solid
sample
or you have solids in your wastewater
sample we often found that both the mhv
or surrogate and sarsko v2 like to
partition into those solids and so this
is again maybe one of those reasons why
understanding how people process their
samples is really important because if
people excluded the solids they may be
excluding a large portion of their viral
measurements in their sample and so
if that lab consistently excluded their
solids
in general i would say their data is
good for observing those trends but if
you were to compare their sample to a
sample
or a lab where they included the solids
in their sample you would get very
different measurements
so that virus concentration and rna
extraction
virus concentration that we started with
36.5 mils of wastewater so after
concentration we got that down and we
extracted down to 60 microliters of rna
extract and then our rna quantification
was predominantly or largely done with
droplet digital
polymerase chain reaction
we use droplet digital a polymerase
chain reaction technically a little bit
more difficult than standard pcr qpcr
we had a little bit better response with
dd pcr with uh
avoiding inhibition from the wastewater
sample so wastewater samples are are
complex samples and there can be
compounds that interfere with your
quantification for pcr and we again tend
to have better luck
in our lab when we were using ddpcr
so our quantitative limit of detection
for this process we were measuring both
n1 and n2 and i'll highlight what those
are here in a second but our
quantification limit of detection was
1.28 gene copies per milliliter of
wastewater and then for n2 was slightly
better at 1.1 gene copies per milliliter
of wastewater
i mentioned quantification and so we use
the cdcsars cov2 primers which have been
um
pretty standard for general qpcr ddpcr
measurements and these wastewater based
epidemiology efforts
and so we use the taqman probe
uh in our ddpcr instruments so the
primers
are available and happy to answer any
questions
around this more specifically if anybody
has those but again this is a largely
established well-established protocol
that the wastewater community has been
using consistently
so i mentioned that uh we partnered with
the douglas county health department
um and they were the ones responsible
for providing the case data
during our
comparison p period and so again we had
our wakarusa sewer shed and our kansas
sewer shed so it was really important
that we didn't just get uh positive case
counts for lawrence we had to understand
where in the sewer sheds
people were contributing
to
you know their feces or their fecal
matter into the wastewater and which
sewer shed and so the assumption here
was largely that if an individual tested
positive they would be at their uh
primary residence and so that's what you
have here is that geocoded positive
cases based on residents and again the
blue would indicate
zero or very low covet 19 cases the red
to orange would indicate high
covet 19 cases and
something to acknowledge as a limitation
is that so we assumed a primary
residence but again lawrence
memorial hospital
was located in the kansas sewer shed so
if you had hospitalized individuals they
would likely be contributing to the
kansas sewer shed even if they had for
example been living in the wakarusa
sewer shed
and so collecting that case data
again can be often very noisy and so you
can use some smoothing curves to
understand general trends and that case
data and so here we have daily new
covenanting cases on the left or y-axis
over the time period of our study
again from june to december 2020 and so
in general we
observed during this period three
large case spikes
for our community
so taking that case data and applying
that against our sars cov22
concentrations and again i'm uh in this
case reporting n1 concentrations on the
y-axis
and in this case only presenting the
data where we normalize to mitochondria
or creatinine those human specific
biomarkers that would be found in the
wastewater
and in the combined sewer sheds so we're
looking at the combined data for both
sewer sheds we see our blue case data
trend those three spikes and then in our
wastewater data we see our three spikes
uh when we normalize creatinine and in
the bottom graph we see in orange
are sars cov2 and one concentrations
when normalized to creatinine
and again i always kind of uh joke i you
got to cross your eyes to kind of see
the trends but there are you know three
spikes in this data and a follow up with
some of the statistical analysis that
were performed so uh to kind of convince
you that these three spikes corresponded
to that case data
we could also divide these out by uh
sewer shed and so in the kansas sewer
shed we saw the mitochon or the
creatinine that top middle graph we see
those three spikes of n1 concentration
and when normalized to creatinine again
those three spikes
the bottom graph is mitochondria those
three spikes
and then in the
wakarusa sewer shed where the data was a
little bit more noisy and a little bit
more difficult to interpret just
visually but the wakarusa sewer shed
also saw some spikes in the n1
concentration
so some of the statistical methods that
you can use to evaluate the quality and
the correlations of your data in this
case we used uh spearman's correlation
data and so a positive correlation here
being all the way up to plus one if you
saw an increase in the sars cov2
concentration in the wastewater you
would also see or you correlated to an
increase in the covet 19 cases a
negative correlation negative one would
be asar's cov2 increase in the
wastewater but then you saw a decrease
in the number of code 19 cases so in
general when we're looking at
correlations between sars cov2
concentration and the wastewater and
covid19
cases we're really wanting to see that
plus one or that strong correlation
between our measurements
and what we observed in the combined
sewer shed when we looked at 21 day
cumulative cases
is that our wastewater measurements were
detecting sars cov2n1 concentrations at
the strongest correlation five and six
days ahead of the case data and the
covet 19 case data
and again our strongest strongest
correlations were observed when we
normalized our concentrations to those
human-based biomarkers so again all uh
everybody's contributing to the sewer
shed this creatinine and this
mitochondria and so these normalizations
give us a sense of that strength of that
waste plotter in a system
so this trend or this observation of
this five or six day uh detection of
sars kov2 concentration of wastewater
versus case data was observed uh very
early on
in
these efforts and so here again in a
paper 2020 where they were looking at
sars cov2 concentrations in primary
sludge
red again they were detecting
sars cov2 concentrations about five days
before the corresponding case data and
again these trended very closely with
that five day gap
however in the earlier stages of that
pandemic the case
clinical testing was very sparse it was
hard to find it was hard to get you had
to have
very clear indications that you were
sick before you could even get testing
however at the university of kansas when
we wanted to try and bring students back
in the fall of 2020
we instituted these high frequency
clinical testing campaigns with very
high turnarounds
and so when we look at more this fall
time period where students are coming
back
i would say that we had probably
greater quality or better quality covet
19 case data with respect to both timing
and just the actual number of
individuals that were sick or testing
positive even if they were asymptomatic
within the community and so across the
board you saw our correlations improve
so we saw much stronger correlations
with our sars cov2 wastewater
concentrations versus that case data
but for both for both n1 and n2 and
again across all of these biomarkers
that we used but again we're still
seeing
stronger correlations with our human
specific creatinine and mitochondria
and again more importantly
we saw that our
correlations didn't have a daily offset
which means or suggests that our source
cov2 concentration wastewater
measurements were giving us a similar uh
community level health information as
these intense high turnaround our fast
turnaround clinical testing campaigns
that we were using in lawrence kansas
now the thing that scientists always
love to say is correlation is not
causation and so just because these are
correlated doesn't necessarily mean that
a six individual uh the more uh
individuals that are uh have coven 19
and a sewer shed doesn't necessarily
mean that it is causing a higher or an
increase sars cov2 concentration in your
wastewater and so we used a slightly
different
statistical method called grainger
causality which is evaluating the
ability in this case of our sars cov2
wastewater concentrations to predict
uh the number of covid19 cases within a
community and so this is not uh taking a
concentration
uh and telling you the number of cases
but it's more looking at trends as we
see our historical trends of sars cov2
concentrations in the wastewater do we
see the same trends in our coven 19 case
data
and in general this is a chord diagram
what we have is again our normalized
sars cov2n1 concentrations to
mitochondria
and creatinine
did have a causal relationship with
those case data with a one day or four
day lag based on this evaluation matrix
and so again this is suggesting that
when you have more individuals
more covenanting cases
in a community
that you're seeing an increase and that
sars cov2 concentration and that those
sars cov2 concentration wastewater
measurements
could be used within one community to
potentially predict the number of cope
with 19 cases
so again this is important that i keep
saying one community because this
relationship was developed based on our
sars cov2 concentrations in wastewater
and so if you were to go to a different
lab who used maybe a slightly different
method
they might get a different report on the
number
uh or that concentration of sars cov2
and so you can't necessarily take that
concentration and divide it by by some
number and get the actual number of
covert 19 cases
so key research outcomes from the case
study so we observe strong correlations
with human specific biomarkers so again
normalizing can play in a really
important role in understanding those
trends
we use creatinine and mitochondria a
very popular one now is that pmmov
peppermild model
virus both biomarkers provide
opportunities to account for stars cov2
characteristics in the wastewater system
so again creatinine was selected because
it has a similar half-life in collection
systems as far as cov2 mitochondria is
selected because it represents that
solids partitioning
that sars cov2 might exhibit and then
granger causality tests indicate
normalized stars cov2 wastewater
concentrations may predict that 21 day
cumulative cases
switching to our last objective
recognizing how an automated workflow
can increase capacity and reduce total
processing time so um
serious nanosciences was developing
these
nano trap magnetic virus particles uh
that could concentrate the virus and
then follow that into the extraction
step and so what
we transitioned to was largely uh
manpower driven peg extraction and a pt
peg concentration rna extraction step
and we combined or modified these two
steps into an automated platform and so
again virus concentration was achieved
by these nano magnetic virus particles
and then rna extraction by a magmax
microbiome ultra kit
which could be automated
in a kingfisher platform and so these
are magnetic bead-based platforms
that
could improve and significantly improved
as i'll show
processing time in labs
before we adopted the platform though we
wanted to evaluate the effectiveness so
just like when we evaluated the four
initial protocols we also evaluated
this automated platform
using or against our peg
and so here on the y-axis you have
percent recovery of our surrogate myriad
hepatitis virus and then on
the x-axis you have these communities
that we've been testing in the state of
kansas
and the first thing that you'll notice
is that the nano trap with the enhance
without the enhancement reagent one and
even with the enhancement reagent one
had we had much higher recoveries of our
mhv virus compared to our peg method and
so again this was uh part of this
narrative is accounting for that solids
and so mhv when we account for both the
solids and the liquid phase of
wastewater our mhv recovery and peg
method could be much higher in the 50
percent but with this automated platform
we didn't have to do that two-stage
recovery and so if we were only looking
at the liquid phase
the nanotraps showed much higher
recoveries of our surrogates
there were cases still where some
utilities we just sublet for example we
were never able uh there's something in
that wastewater that's very interesting
we were never able to recover neither
our uh mhv surrogate
nor the saurus cov2
in those samples
looking at comparison of ct so this is
that
threshold level by which you detect
n1 concentrations and in this case qpcr
so the lower the number
the quicker you might detect n1
concentrations in your wastewater sample
and again the general trend is that the
red squares are higher which is the
automated platform magnetic nanotrap
particles with the enhancement region
one
blue being in general some of these that
are similar to our original peg methods
and that would be the no enhancement
reagent one and then we have an x
rpeg method
so again we were seeing both enhanced
recovery of our surrogate virus as well
as earlier detection
or lower ct value for detection of n1
and our qpcr samples
they kind of give you a sense of the
amount of time saved
we look i kind of prepared this table if
we're looking at processing 24 samples
and so we have these procedural steps of
preparation virus concentration and
viral rna extraction so these are kind
of the steps before
the
virus quantification and our preparation
12 v peg is very difficult to make and
is very viscous and so it's also very
difficult to handle and so preparation
was uh much higher about four hours with
two undergraduate students and a
technician whereas in the automated uh
platform we have a much shorter
time and
the reagents are much easier to work
with they're not nearly as viscous as
that 12 pg
virus concentration
three hours one undergraduate one
technician
largely
a lot of this time is focused on
centrifugation
so for peg there's a two hour
centrifugation
that was required
now for virus concentration it's mostly
one technician
and this is mostly runtime on the
automated platform
virus rna extraction again when we're
doing the 12 peg method we had to
transfer uh the concentrated viral
particles into
our rna extraction and again this was
about three hours one undergraduate or
technician
um and then now on this automated
platform we're at one hour and so if
you're looking at just total processing
time to get 24 samples in our lab the pg
method would take us 10 uh hours
and a combination of at least two
undergraduate students and a technician
whereas now we're at four hours and
mostly working with a technician
but also an undergraduate student
helping sample preparation
or
help process preparation
and so again this automated platform
allowed us to expand our testing
throughout the state of kansas and so
this is you know the red dots are just
showing higher concentrations and we
expanded this testing for 95 counties in
the state of kansas
and one of the important things that
also let us do is that this testing when
we first started was mostly quarterly
and i'll show that uh here in a few
moments that if you really want to
detect these trends you've got to be
much more frequent than that and so the
automated platform allowed us to move to
at least bi-weekly testing if not more
frequent
and to kind of show you what that data
looks like i'll highlight six
communities that we're evaluating
so a wastewater facility in johnson
county atchison kansas concordia hayes
colby and
wichita so these are all again
municipalities in kansas and so when
we've moved to the more to that high
frequency testing you can start to see
these trends and that
n1 sars cov2 concentration in these
samples and again you need that kind of
more high resolution that kind of weekly
or bi-weekly sampling to catch these
spikes and that n1 concentration that
you observe and all of these communities
whereas if we were still just testing
quarterly we'd miss that
we also started and we're able to start
uh sequencing and so we are doing
sequencing now with arctic version three
primers 75 76 alternative and 77
and we're running my seek pooled three
month sample runs
and
we started this in 2021 and so some of
our first data here is for october
november december 2021 and for the most
part when you look at october in kansas
we're largely seeing you know these
kind of what i refer to as these legacy
variants so covet 19 some of the
variants that were introduced in
2020
in november we start to see or detect
delta and then really in december of
2021 is where we start to see
that omicron pop up in this particular
lawrence community
if we look at all 13 kansas communities
this was similar trends for the most
part when we're looking at october
um you know the percent variants in
these communities were mostly
uh those legacy 2019 2020 variants uh
and some of the communities we did see
delta and it really wasn't until
december 2021 where we start to see
omicron pop up in some of these
communities
and the uh encouraging thing about this
wastewater sequencing data is that we
detected omicron
occurring or popping up at the same time
as our clinical testing and so if we
look at the clinical testing data across
the state
most of what was being detected in
october was delta all the way up until
december where then in december you
started seeing omicron pop up in these
clinical testing uh cases
again always the interesting thing is
why do we see some of the 1920 variants
in our wastewater that are predominant
versus the clinical testing which is
mostly sawing delta and then later on a
little bit omicron is still a very
interesting question
that we're pursuing
so summary from this presentation
again from the case study strong
correlations were observed with human
specific biomarkers creatinine and
mitochondria
both biomarkers provide opportunities to
account for sars cov2 characteristics in
that wastewater system so either the
half-life or solas partitioning
again grainger causality test indicate
normalized source cov2 wastewater
concentrations may predict our 21-day
accumulated cases and then for us the
automated platform enabled higher
frequency state wide testing and varied
tracking via sequencing
just like to take a moment this has been
a very large group effort
professor belinda sturm
and i helped get this off the ground in
early 2020 lots of undergraduate
students and technicians have been
helping with this process
and so like just take a moment to
acknowledge the students and co-workers
that have been involved also a lot of
the cities who partnered with us on the
early stages of this city of lawrence
johnson county and olathe
also like to take a moment to
acknowledge funding sources so candace
department health environment patterson
foundation serious nanosciences
university of kansas chemical biology
infectious disease uh university of
kansas center for molecular analysis of
disease pathways sequencing was provided
by the university of kansas genome
sequencing core
and then financial support also provided
by the national institute of health
under grant number
listed there
and with that um happy to take any
questions i left some of the conclusions
up as people formulate questions and
like i mentioned i'm happy to take any
questions
thank you dr hutchison for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen we'll
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for
all right let's get started our first
question asks
and mentions it's impressive that you
built this program from the ground up
what are your top three learnings that
you would share with a lab just starting
this path of
surveillance yes so thanks for the great
question i think um kind of the three
things i would i strongly encourage
someone
if they're just starting this out is
first operator relationships municipal
relationships so we really would not
have been able to do this work if we
didn't have all of these operators uh in
kansas sending these uh wastewater
samples
uh through the mail i'm sure i probably
also have to thank uh shipping
entities for
you know probably not questioning too
much that we're shipping a bunch of
wastewater across the united states and
i'm sure the massive amount of increase
in the number of wastewater samples that
were being shipped across the united
states was very large
again still
building that community again leverage
any networks that already integrate with
operators in your
in this case in the united states states
and so we have state-based
professional societies we were also able
to leverage to help connect us to the
municipalities for this effort
and then also
kind of a two-part understanding the
limitations of wastewater surveillance
so it took a lot of work for us to be
able to take our wastewater
concentrations that we were measuring in
one community and connect those to the
case data and so that took a lot of work
but then also bringing on those people
so again the local county health
departments in our case
bringing those people on board to be
willing to give us the data to help us
interpret the data on the case data side
because you know i think we tend to
focus that there's a lot of uncertainty
on the wastewater side but i think
there's also a lot of uncertainty on the
clinical testing side of things and
especially now that we enter the stage
of the pandemic where
not all but a lot of testing in the
united states or people testing at home
and they don't always report if they
have a positive case or not
thank you for that question
great thank you
next question here what is next for
kansas for wastewater testing
it's uh always an interesting question
so we've been working on kind of one
year timelines and our timeline uh for
this round of testing is coming up in
june 30th and so we're
still trying to figure out how we're and
and who is going to do this but i think
the uh
important and kind of cool thing about
this wastewater based epidemiology
efforts is this idea that this is really
kind of a very powerful community health
tool
that a lot of health departments are
using now in their toolbox and so there
has been
a wide variety of interest across the
state to continue these efforts
and again that june 30th there may be
some transition
at the university side of things
we just have uh
an nsf project launching called adaptive
and resilient infrastructures driven by
social equity and so a lot of these
concepts
will be used in
assuring that collection systems
especially in under
invested communities are updated so that
um you know those wastewater collection
systems
can cause leakages for example into
other communities or into drinking water
systems so these are combined sewer
overflows and sanitary sewer overflows i
should pause
and back up a sec
so because we have aged infrastructure
in a lot of communities when it rains or
uh even just when there are increased
amounts of sewage
flow in a collection system this can
sometimes overload the treatment systems
and there's these raw sewage discharges
these raw sewage discharges can affect
communities both locally if you had an
infrastructure breakage within the
community or in downstream communities
for example on the kansas river where an
upstream community releases and then it
impacts the downstream and so a lot of
these uh again expanding beyond sars
kovi ii a lot of these tools are usable
in other infectious disease and so we'll
be using these tools
to both
monitor and then also suggest
improvements in infrastructure systems
across the state of kansas
great thank you
next question how effective were the
tests and were or will those results be
available to the community and where
would we be able to find these results
online
so uh we did publish at least the case
theta set um in fem's article i think
the slides are going to be released
after this presentation and so there's a
citation for
that has my last name hutchison and so
uh the lawrence case data uh is already
out there on the internet so if you can
just you know search google hutcheson
sarsko v2 uh that article will probably
pop up
and um
all of the corresponding underlying data
is available on mendeley data so we
we in addition to the publication we
shared all of our raw data as a data
publication
another question here what type of
analyzer are you using
i'm sorry could you repeat that question
yes what type of analyzer are you using
so um this uh is a multi-layered
question i think it depends on
which specific aspect of the testing
that you're asking about so for the
concentration and rna extraction we're
now using the series nanoscience
nanotrap beads
particles
the magmax rna extraction and the
kingfisher platform and then that
transitions once you start doing the
quantification the bio-rad
droplet digital pcr
system and then for sequencing we're
using the my seek run
great thank you
your next question here asks can you
list your lod again
yes um
i write these down because i am very
particularly bad at memorizing this so
the n1 quantitative limit of detection
was 1.28 gene copies per milliliter
wastewater and for n2 it's 1.1 gene
copies per milliliter of wastewater
great we have time for a few more
questions here this next one asks what
are your methods for normalizing for
creatinine and mitochondria
so for creatinine we used an elisa test
so this is just a colorimetric
intensity test based on the
concentration of creatinine in the
sample and then for mitochondria dna we
developed a qpcr assay and the primers
and again all of that information uh is
also located in the publication
thank you
next question
when using the liquid phase only for
nanotrap beads do you pre-process the
sample in any way in an effort to
release additional virus particles from
the solid phase first
so the only pre-processing step that we
have right now is that enhancement
reagent one so we do add that
which again
in our our assessment showed an
increased recovery of our mhv and also
uh across the majority of our uh
participating municipalities showed an
increase in the n1
concentrations our ability to detect the
n1 concentrations in our samples
with the transition from the platform we
stopped uh pre-centrifugation so we are
also now including the solids
in our wastewater samples so again
there's kind of a transition point
between objective one and two and
objective three so in objective one and
two we did pre-centrifuge to separate
our solids for the peg method but then
after and once we transitioned to the
other platform we stop doing the
pre-centrifugation step
great
well looks like we have time for one
more question so we'll go ahead and wrap
up with this one and it asks for your
creatinine etc correlations you use your
raw gene copies of virus per volume of
sewage cdc and majority of dashboards
are normalizing the end concentrations
to the total daily influent flow and
then sewer shed population do you think
this is the correct data to use for
those normalization correlations with
case data then
so that is an excellent question and
you're not going to like me because i'm
not going to say there's a right way yet
i think there's a lot of work out there
trying to figure this out um
we
generally still report concentration
data for most of our municipalities the
reason why we do concentration data when
we're just directly reporting to
municipalities some of them have lagoon
systems and so in those lagoon systems
it's really hard to get a sense of the
flow in and out of those lagoon systems
however in in when we're analyzing the
data we do take into account the flow
data and then that is also taken into
account when we use those normalizing
biomarkers
we also
have looked at potentially normalizing
to population but when we were looking
at lawrence again we tended to avoid
that for two reasons we had some pretty
large shifts in population
over the course of the pandemic and so
how did we account for that large shift
in population was really difficult
the other thing to be aware of is
depending on how you're collecting your
sample the number of people contributing
to a collection system varies so
for example
this is more anecdotal from my children
but my children tend not to like to poop
at school and so they'll wait they won't
poop during the day at school they'll
wait till they go home and so again you
have these discrepancies of when people
are using
the wastewater collection system and so
those can be a hard to account for when
you talk about just a population number
and so that's why we tended to prefer
those human specific normalizing
biomarkers that we actually measured in
the wastewater
we did try to take back
the biomarker concentration into an
actual population number
the creatinine
showed that we were generally about an
order of magnitude
population estimate lower which would
suggest that creatine creatinine is
probably degrading in the system and
likewise sars cov2 would be degrading in
that collection system
the mitochondria normalization needs
more work
there have been efforts to quantify the
number of mitochondria that an
individual sheds and there have been
efforts to quantify mitochondria and
wastewater collected at the municipality
but when you try to back calculate the
number of individuals based on those
numbers
we ended up estimating that like
lawrence had a population of like 1
million which is much higher than what
we actually have in lawrence and so
there's still some work on these
normalizing biomarkers
if you want to try and get a sense of
the exact number of people
contributing to that system
great
well thank you again dr hutchison for
your time today and your important
research we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor saris nanosciences
excuse me for underwriting today's
educational webcast before we go i'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions questions we did not have time
for today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time take care
everyone goodbye
you